The Exorcist is a movie that changed
horror and it still stands as an amazing
piece of filmmaking that so many have
tried to imitate billed with incredibly
creepy imagery hidden details and a lot
of things that you have to figure out on
your own this is the kind of movie that
I think is perfect for a breakdown often
dubbed is the scariest film of all time
The Exorcist is probably a movie that
you heard about long before you ever saw
it as a kid I remember its reputation
being something that preceded it I can
vividly recall a special edition advert
being shown on TV which even managed to
give me nightmares even though it was
shorter than Pete Davidson's last
relationship now upon finally plucking
up the courage to watch it as a kid I
could definitely see why this was a film
that people were still talking about
decades later there's things in this
movie that will stick with you forever
and the laceright Reagan strapped to her
bed is probably one of the most iconic
images in film history
although it's got this mass of
reputation the movie itself off actually
had much simpler beginnings and the
story began Life as a bug by author
William bloody bloody actually makes a
cameo later on in the movie and he too
plays someone working on the film
alongside Burke based on the real-life
Exorcism of Rolando bloody changed up
the details of that to all of the sex
and age of the Apparently possessed
victim Dell was of course a pseudonym
but since bloody was taking creative
license he didn't rely too heavily on
knowing the true details of the case now
on that theatrical cup Blu-ray director
William friedkin talks about how he was
fascinated with the story which took
place in Georgetown though it's
horrifying Regan did say that the child
grew up having no memory of the event
and that he actually went on to have a
successful career at Nasa the bully's
family apparently went through all his
stages we see Reagan going through in
the film and they also visited doctors
psychologists and sought advice from
friends before eventually going to the
church weirdly the bug itself failed to
sell well in its first run and it left
the author in dire Financial Straits
however it gained a lot autocritical
Acclaim and good word of mouth helped it
to be picked up by movie studios around
Hollywood obviously it would go on to
become a mammoth movie and I think at
the heart of its success lies the idea
that people almost feel like they're
confirming their faith when they go to
see it the book's obviously based on a
true story and it boils down to a battle
between the Catholic church and the
forces of evil due to its reputation the
movie almost feels like a test to watch
and when you go through it you're very
much seeing if you can be the devil as
well and come out the other side there's
also of course many myths and legends
that always surround movies like this
and just like the Yeoman rumors of
Supernatural things happening on set
were part and parcel of the marketing
less lesser curse is real
Now The Exorcist is filled with several
subliminal images that really added the
horror on a deeper level appearing on
screen for a split second these frames
embed themselves into our subconscious
and are nervous even though they happen
so quickly that we barely even register
them
the film basically boils down to bazuzu
possessing Reagan and throughout it we
get several flashes of his face to let
us know he's always watching some of
these images are toned down depending on
what version you watch and the RFP that
only appear in the theatrical version
however I've gone through both films for
this to point out when they happen and
hopefully when you revisit the movie
you'll find a new appreciation of it
now early on the farm we see the statue
of Pazuzu and this later appears in
Reagan's bedroom this is pretty obvious
and well lit so we instantly see it over
in the theatrical cut there's a hidden
statue in the room that only eagle-eyed
viewers will spot as Chris leaves at
Doro Reagan's room we take a lot of
focus on her walking through the house
and you might not notice it but pazuzu's
actually in this Frame upon boosting the
brightness you can catch his statue in
the corner and this adds an extra layer
of horror to this very mundane moment
there's also a quick flash of the
statue's hair that we get when she opens
the door I've slowed this right down so
you can see it but it appears on screen
for what's basically three frames and it
gives the idea that Pazuzu is waiting in
this room his face is throughout the
house so when Christopher centers the
kitchen we can see it flickering and out
but what's roughly a second it's gone
just as quickly as it arrives but it's
so creepy and unnerving a lot of these
are Circle was made in a time before
physical media allowed people to pause
and Rewind films and there's many
watching it might have wondered if they
saw what they thought they saw this face
is something which is constant
throughout the film and it pops in and
out of scenes at several points in the
movie jiren Reagan's examination at
roughly the 33 minute Mark we see her
eyes open As She lays on the bed the
demon then quickly flashes on screen
just before it vanishes and though this
is a very low-key scene this instantly
grabs your attention later on a similar
shot appears in Father charis's dreams
and we can catch the demon as he runs
towards his mother in a blink and you'll
miss a moment Pazuzu appears in between
the cuts letting us know that he hasn't
backeded the character's mind we also
get a moment just before this where we
see charis's mother in a dark black room
and this is shot in a similar way to how
the Demon's face appears now a shot of
the demon appears like this later on
during the exorcism at roughly the one
hour 45 Mark I'm saying roughly because
depending on what version you watch
there will be different scenes at throw
the timing off anyway as Reagan's being
exercised we see the lights flicker on
and off and during one of these black
spots we get a quick flash of Pazuzu a
Pazuzu isn't the only face that flashes
on screen and we actually get charis's
mother up here just before he jumps out
the window when the father takes the
demon into himself he looks about the
curtains and you can catch the face of
his mother fading in and out
superimposition is used brilliantly in
the film as well and at roughly the one
hour two minute Mark we see Reagan turn
ahead to the camera during the hypnosis
scene in a blank and you'll miss a
moment we get a few frames where the
demons superimposed over the top of her
face just before she attacks this is
repeated later on roughly at the 1 hour
45 Mark when she turns and looks
directly at the camera comes right after
the head turn and if you pause the frame
then you'll notice the left side of her
face actually has pazuz there are two
eyes together in that area and it really
adds to how creepy that this moment is
it's such a nice touch that throws the
viewer off slightly and it also lets us
now there's two entities trapped inside
this one body that is of course Reagan
and the demon and it's moments like this
that really added the film The Director
really stretched the limits of tarot
within a film as well and he went beyond
shots like this to tie with us on an
aura level sound is used expertly
throughout the bomb with breedkin also
adding in unsettling noise is so that we
can never feel relaxed Pig squeals are
used when Reagan's tossing and turning
and the son of bees is placed at several
points early on in the film
oh
[Music]
now if you're enjoying the video then
the power of YouTube compels you the
power of YouTube compels you to hit the
thumbs up button and don't forget to
subscribe for breakdowns like this on
the best movies ever made now for the
rest of the video I will be going
through the entire directors cut scene
by scene to talk about all the Creepy
Hidden details in it that elevate the
film I did watch both versions for this
breakdown but without having more stuff
in it I think it's probably the best
place to focus on now the longer code
actually begins with two shots that
aren't included in a theatrical and in
this we start off at the house before we
cut to the Virgin Mary statue personally
I find this a bit weird and and know
that the Exorcist band Community share
the same belief basically starts as a
confusing way to kick things off because
we immediately jump from here over to a
rack the original theatrical cut began
in Iraq and skipped over these scenes
which just throws us straight into the
mystery normally when you're making
establishing shots like this you don't
then want to jump over to another
location but I think it's put in place
because this is where the demon
manifests houses are supposed to be
places of security where we can relax
and well be at home Aura tends to
subvert this though when it places the
danger in with us which subconsciously
throws us off the house of course balls
from the film's extremely famous poster
which is a shot taken from Marin's
arrival in Georgetown with the light
beaming out of the window like what we
get here they may have wanted to start
things off by just referencing what this
film's known for it's also how the film
closes out too with his getting focused
on it brought it up and the statue
course gets desecrated which sets it up
later down the line now the use of this
window actually took inspiration from
the artist Renee Magritte and namely is
Empire of light paintings which bear
somewhat of resemblance to what we see
now what I think the Exorcist does
brilliantly is that it doesn't spell the
information out for you when you have to
figure things out as you watch the movie
throughout the film you're meant to take
in the information and fill in the
blanks and this is definitely seen in
the case of the statue as we never learn
who vandalized it whether there is a
clue 2 and the statue is covered in clay
which we know Reagan has access to in
the film she makes clay animals near the
start and though she does have a way of
carrying this act out this also ties in
the Burke's death which I'll talk about
more later on in the video but there is
a clue that Reagan was involved with
this as well Lieutenant killed him in at
one point searches the spot where Burke
died at and we see that he finds a
little clay model kinnamon later comes
across one in the home when he meets
Chris for the first time and he asks if
Reagan made it the shows that the
character was involved in that the
vandalism and it also ties in with
Pazuzu brilliantly this is also meant to
reference the Pazuzu head we see
throughout the movie and it shows that
Reagan visited the scene at some point
anyway after the titles we cut to Iraq
and find father Marin played by Max von
siddau the actor was actually 44 at the
time but they added old age makeup to
him to make him seem more mature this is
one of those guys to me who was seemed
like he was old forever and now knowing
that they did this in one of his most
famous appearances it does start to make
sense the freaking did film on location
for this happening and you can see how
much authenticity that it adds to the
movie he could have easily just put this
on a set but it adds to the gripping
feeling that we get in this opening
breedkin didn't have it easy either and
this was due to Iraq and U.S relations
at the time Americans had been forbidden
from filming there and as freedkin had
to hire an old British crew and promised
the government that he teached them some
of their film techniques this opening is
often forgotten when you think back on
the movie but it easily sets the tone
for the rest of the film at the base of
the mound Mariners introduced digging
and this is alongside the rest of the
workers there it sets him up as a humble
figure escalating the idea that this is
very much a small man versus an
insurmountable evil discovering the
statue head of bazuzu we see Dustin blow
and this happens as he pulls it out
thank you
now bazuzu is actually a demon who's
said to be the personification of the
northwest wind there's lots of texts on
him and in the Legends he'd use this to
carry across disease and famine wind is
summing at signals the characters in the
air and at several points in the film we
see it blowing to signify his arrival
anyway in the next shot we see a man
pouring liquid out of a spout that looks
like a pig with wings the Pazuzu statue
is a winged beast and bear-like
creatures appear throughout the film to
subliminally carry this idea Reagan
Creator giant clay bird and when Charis
goes through her drawings we see that
she's also created some creepy birds and
a winged lion the Pazuzu statue also has
a snake fruit and later on the Virgin
Mary statue is given one by Reagan using
the clay models anyway Maron makes his
way through the city and we very much
get the idea that there's an evil
presence watching him throughout
friedkin massively shoots the scene so
that there's this constant feeling of
paranoia and it feels like he's either
being watched by the demon or by his
bosses this is hinatua us when Marin
comes across a group of men hammering
away and one removes his hat and Reveals
His Eye we can see that he's blind in
one and this appears that'll almost be
fully white this was done on purpose
with it deliberately appearing similar
to the white eyes that Reagan gets later
on in the movie Maron has of course
faced up against demons before so we can
see why this would be so unnerving to
him now we cut to an office switches
where we get focus on a clock and then
the statue head yeah Marin looks at a
Saint Joseph medal that was on Earth
during the day again this seemingly
appears later on at the start of
charis's dream now necklace identical to
this was actually worn by his mother
which has caused a lot of fun
speculation as being said by the
creative team that the medals are in
fact different but they symbolize why
these two characters eventually end up
coming together Karis later wears his
mother's medal and it's theorized that
Reagan actually rips us off at the end
of the film because the demon needs its
protection torn away so that it can
enter his body it's later given as a
gift at the end of the movie and this
symbol realizes that the ordeal is now
over and when Marin's looking at the
Pazuzu head the man in the office says
evil against evil though bazuzu is an
evil entity it's actually so evil that
it would drive other evil spirits away
because it was thought to have made a
claim and the clock then stops behind
meron and I believe this symbolizes the
demons telling him that his time is up
he's nearly hit by a speeding cart later
on and God's rushing when he's getting
out of his car nice little detail here
is that we can actually see a crack in
his windscreen and many have theorized
this is a gunshot Mark possibly hinging
out that he's been fired up before
Marilyn catches the statue with his son
on its back and this creates a chilling
silhouette the Iraq scene itself starts
off with the sun with this blocking its
symbolic of the darkness that pazuzu's
now bringing a strange man watches Marin
the wind blows dogs start to fight now
we get the feeling that something is
coming
[Applause]
now from here we go to Georgetown which
is where we're introduced to Chris after
hearing some strange noises in the Attic
she goes into Reagan's room to find the
window open and the curtains blowing in
the wind Pazuzu has arrived and we let
alone Reagan's been communicating with
someone called Captain howdy through the
use of a Ouija board the name howdy is
very important because it's used as a
way to manipulate Reagan and make her
start to trust this evil entity later on
we see a magazine cover with both Chris
and Reagan on it and this tells us that
the former is going through a divorce is
actually also names Reagan's dad as
being Howard and howdy is a nickname for
Howard so her not really seeing her
father that much could be why this was
chosen to make her open up more now the
films there were introduced to Bear can
we see Chris in her element breedkin
originally wanted Audrey Hepburn for the
role and this would help to give us the
idea that she was a glamorous movie star
working on a production anyway we get an
echo of the scene with Marin and see
Chris walking through the streets to the
tune popular Bells this has very much
become The Exorcist theme re-watching
the movie I was surprised at how little
the themes actually used when it's used
it's for moments like this but it does
make even the more simple things seem
unnerving Chris has passed in the street
by children dressed up as things for
Halloween and we also see nuns walking
by with their cloaks blowing in the wind
these moments were put in place to show
that religion is all around her but she
refuses to really acknowledge it or take
it seriously it creates his almost
otherworthy feeling and Chris ends up
hearing carrots talking about how his
mother's unable to be treated this is
drowned out by the sound of an airplane
but Karis being unable to take care of
his mother is one of the reasons his
face shaking seeing her whether into
nothing with him being helpless to stop
it it has just broken him unless he
doesn't share the love for Christianity
that he used to have he refuses to help
a homeless man that claims to be a
Catholic and walks you downtrodden
neighborhoods refusing to acknowledge
the rot sound is used expertly too with
a truck
screeching and almost growling and
screaming of the city really catches you
off guard and it makes the streets feel
like they're their own living and
breathing entity in Reagan's basement we
can see the clay models and also catch a
collar ship behind her huge alerts to
Rob AJ and he pointed out that we have
the world from Little Red Riding herd up
to the top left this of course has the
wolf dressing up as a meager old woman
and this is so it can appear a certain
way this is similar how the demon wears
Reagan throughout the movie and both
stories feature the creatures spouting
things off whilst they're sat in a bed
rub also pointed out that we have the
story of Hansel and Gretel on the right
with a witch wearing a blue cloak that's
the exact same color as the jumper that
Reagan wears in the scene now Chris
finds the Ouija board and though she
goes to play with it Reagan refuses to
let her touch it anyway we get a couple
of calm scenes where there to keep the
tension lower and watch Charis dealing
with his mother we learned that he had a
passion for Psychiatry which has helped
him deal with those that come to him for
help the church paid his way to medical
school and since then he's been someone
who priests can go to for therapy you
also learn that Reagan's father never
called her on her birthday and it's
these vulnerabilities that the demon
uses to sink its claws in now we cut to
Chris waking up in the night and on her
bedside we can see a picture of Reagan
clasping her hands together this is of
course symbolic of a prayer and it's
something that Chris later does in front
of it during the hypnosis scene when the
demons within Reagan she too joins her
hands like this and from the look on her
face in the photo we're meant to draw
the religious connections to see how
she's praying for help Reagan talks
about how her bed was shaking and we cut
to a shot of the attic to once more let
us know that there's something up there
upon opening up friedkin layers the
sound of wind into the ladder to end to
us our captain Howdy's coming
foreign
we get a quick shot of Reagan sitting
with her eyes open and then cut to the
test with howdy appearing on screen as
she looks up in the waiting room we see
two boys fighting and this may be
building off the back of the two dogs
fighting at the start of the movie
that's probably a reach but there's this
continuing idea of chaos whenever the
demons around doctors are unable to see
what's going on and thus they just
prescribe Ritalin and hope the problem
goes away anyway we see Charis visiting
his mother in an asylum and this was
actually done for real with many of the
women being mental patients using hidden
cameras where you can film some of these
moments and the dress and bed shots we
see Echo the look Reagan gets later on
now from here we go to the party and
meet father Dyer played by an actual
priest he helped the consult on the film
and also advised things it's through him
that we learn charis's mother passed
away after being left by herself and
know it's a throwaway line it shows the
movie wants you to connect the dots
yourself now that's very much the case
when it comes to Berk's death 2 we catch
him insinuating that one of the staff
members 2x for Chris is a Nazi and later
on he's found at the bottom of the steps
his head is completely turned around and
with Reagan's bedroom window being close
to this it is suspected that he was
thrown out of it a Pazuzu actually
confirmed that they killed Burke by
making fun of his Twisted head and
saying this you know what she did
shows that the demon broke Burke's neck
before throwing him out of the window
much like what kinderman suspects I just
before Berks are [__] out we get a shot
of Chris putting Reagan to bed now we
can see the window open with the wind
blowing the party guys play piano which
is when Reagan interrupts them and
urinates on the floor again her dress is
very much echoing the Asylum patience
and the people that think that she's
troubled rather than being possessed
he's put to bed and then after Chris he
has her screaming she rushes in to see
her bed jumping about now what you might
not know is that this actually caused
real life injury to Linda Blair and she
badly fractured her back when filming
this scene led to years of health issues
with her and Ellen burstin didn't escape
the film and skate either during the
scene in which Reagan throws her to the
floor the stuntman actually yanked the
wire too hard and this also left the
actress with back problems that plagued
her for decades with NC tests being
carried out as the doctors try and get
to the bottom of what's going on and
these are traumatic as hell now in
talking about The Exorcist you'll
probably hear stories about about people
fainting and walking out of the film
when they were watching it in theaters
this helped to build towards its
reputation but what a lot of people
don't know is that most of the walkouts
happen during these scenes just not nice
seeing a kid put through tests like this
and I don't even think we'll get away
with putting them in the video so
they're probably played by my editors
you have things like needles going in
necks with blood spreading out Extremely
Loud machines and they're deliberately
put in place to torture Reagan and the
viewer there's also a hidden killer in
these scenes too not like it's part of
the movie but an actual killer killer at
one point we see a bearded radiologist
loading Reagan into a scanner this is
actually convicted murderer Paul bites
in who was suspected of being a serial
killer that hunted gay men William freed
can actually use this as the basis for
his Movie cruising which stood out
Pacino and it sended on the murders that
Paul was believed to have carried out
anyway when they're looking over the
X-ray results we see a nurse popper head
in and this is actually a cameo by Linda
Blair's real-life mother the doctors
visit the house and they see firsthand
what's going on with Reagan but all this
does is lead to more traumatizing tests
appearing much like the video Mario saw
we see how Chris is a broken woman now
who's very much at a Wit's End
Psychiatry is suggested she goes home
defeated and we see her driving home
past a big group of people and also an
ambulance again we have to put together
what's going on here but this is
actually the side of Burke's death who
in the next scene we learned was left
alone with Reagan the windows wide open
and the wind is blowing in and Burke was
supposed to be up there with her but
he's nowhere to be seen at this point
Chris learns the bad news and
drunkenness is blamed on Burke falling
down the stairs and from here we get the
spider scene in which Reagan crawls down
the stairs backwards his scene was
originally removed from the movie
because the wires in it could be seen
there was also a moment in which
Reagan's tongue popped out like a snake
and this was just seen as being a bit
too goofy friedkin thought it undercut
the moment in which Chris laneberg's
death so they steered cleared from it
until they were able to change things
digitally either way we kept a Reagan
under hypnosis now we can see that her
right arms held up this is another
subtle nod to Pazuzu and when we look at
the Statue of him we can see that one
arm is also raised like what we have
here anyway from here we go to Karis
running whilst kinderman watches on he
says she look like a boxer you can catch
photos of Charis in the ring earlier in
the film YouTube channel master of the
Macabre did a brilliant breakdown on
kinderman and they talked about the
techniques that he used throughout the
film he gets people to open up to him
because he comes across as a friend and
in the end this allows him to ask more
questions but Karis he says you like
movies very much well I get passes to
the best shows in town Mrs Kayla you
know she gets tired you know never likes
to go
too bad yeah I hate to go alone you know
I'll have to talk film
disgust to critique
you want to see your film with me later
on with Chrissy leaves by asking if he
can have an autograph that's okay
I really hate to ask you this but
for my daughter could you please give an
autograph and what's your name
I lied it's for me
although he's a fan of film this is
basically him flattering her so they
don't end on a bad note and if they meet
again then she's less likely to be
defensive she ends his meeting with
Charis by making a joke and therefore
he's more likely to be friendly with him
if he comes snooping around again
Exorcist 3 did make it out like they
were great great friends which kind of
recording that a bit mate but these
scenes at least make it seem like they
had at least a friendly Rapport now
whilst he finds the clay model at the
side of Burke's death we see as Chris
disco as a crucifix in Reagan's bedroom
this is the same one that Reagan later
uses to well you know and you might
wonder how this gets from here back to
her bedroom in the next scene Rob Adria
actually did a video documenting it and
when kinnamon arrives you can see Chris
put it on the table she then sits and
has a meeting with him and upon going
back outside the crucifix is gone
showing that Reagan grabbed it during
this time now if they got any Charis
Chris convinces him to see her daughter
and we get a call back to the homeless
man from before father
and you're helping all all the boys
father
Reagan also vomits on Charis when he
asks questions as I'm sure you can guess
this was done only in one take and the
reaction to it is actually real it was
supposed to just hit Jason Miller in the
chest but it mister went into his face
which is why he looks as shocked as he
is he does sing Reagan is Faking it
though due to the demon saying that the
devil and also the fact that they don't
know charis's name even though she's
strapped down we also get a creepy
Shadow looming in her window which
kinderman sees from across the street
now he cut to Karis listening to tapes
and can also catch a banana that says to
sukiti butchered that but the word means
help me in Japanese and this phrase also
appears on Reagan not too long after now
this was achieved by Linda Blair lying
below a firm latex replica of her
stomach with the words being written on
with a paintbrush and also some cleaning
fluid but the foam and fluid had a
reaction with one another which then
caused the words to Bubble up and come
out anyway we begin the first exorcism
of Reagan which is carried out by Karis
but an excellent day for an exorcism
you'd like that
but wouldn't that drive you out of
Reagan
it would bring us together a spoiler
alert but this is what happens at the
end with the exorcism bringing the demon
and Charis together Charis also asks the
demon its name and it replies
this translates to the pen of my aunt
and it's a phrase that's become a joke
in French education because it's taught
to people trying to learn the language
even though it's completely nonsensical
now later on Maron asks Chris if Reagan
has a middle name and in Catholicism
they actually have a tie to possession a
long time ago it saw the demons needed
to know your name in order to possess
you and thus having a middle name men it
was more difficult because people rather
use them although he says he used holy
water Charis reveals is actually just
tap water making things seem less
Supernatural however upon recording her
screams he's able to play them backwards
kind of feel like this might be another
Stairway to Heaven by Led Zeppelin which
was released just two years prior was
said to have satanic messages in it if
you played the song backwards and it
might be kind of referencing that though
it could also be a rich now in the
screams he hears the word meron and upon
requesting an exorcism from the church
that's who he's paired up with Marin's
past is revealed and he arrives and puts
the demon through the exorcism nowaday
amazed the breath will just be done
digitally but to me you can always tell
when they fake it like my last
girlfriend yeah though they had to deal
the set and have it below freezing in
order for it to be cold enough to
produce these effects I think Linda
Blair really comes into her own hair and
she embodies the demon in her amazing
performance I think you'd be
hard-pressed to find a kid who could
pull this kind of thing off and she
really turns it to a twisted and
horrifying monster the effects do a
brilliant job too with a head spinning
added in and they even have wrath coming
out of that to make it seamless fake now
she's also aided by Mercedes McCain
Bridge he was hired to perform the
Demon's iconic voice before recording
she swallowed raw eggs chain smoked
drank lots of alcohol and it all helped
to mess up her voice for the film now
you can really see why so many movies
have tried to imitate this but they
really fail to capture the level of fear
and salty The Exorcist brings though
they have a lot of over the top things
happening they also have the more
chilling horror such as Kara centering
the room by himself to find his mother
sat in bed charis's biggest I guess the
word is Regret his biggest regret is
that he feels like he abandoned his
mother to die on her own though he tried
to be there she passed away in her bed
and the demons tormenting Karis here by
manifesting as her she also butts on her
voice and Marin decides to take over
which allows bazuzu to enact its pot of
the plan we never actually see Miranda's
death until the Exorcist 2 which I won't
go into and instead Charis discovers him
keeled over with Reagan on the bed
giggling Charis attacks which leads to
the necklace being ripped off and at
this point the demon ends up entering
him hurtling down the stairs we can
guess enough yet to understand what
happened with Burke and the movie allows
us to fill in the blanks now when we see
his body lying at the bottom of the
stairs we can also see graffiti on the
left that says fight pigs this is
actually a reference to the Bible itself
namely the story in which Jesus
exercises him demons into a head of pigs
although Charis dies Reagan is okay and
at the bottom of the steps dies absolves
Charis of his sins and gave him his last
right we do learn things about what
really happened here in The Exorcist 3
but I feel like that's a story for
another breakdown now again with a
family picking up and leaving and
originally we ended on a more ambiguous
note freaking said that this was his
vision for some time but bloody was very
much of the idea that they needed to add
a bit more to it this is why we get the
lingering shots and moments with
kinnamon and Daya that give us a bit
more of a hopeful and optimistic funnel
scene Chris Gibbs died the necklace but
he returns it to the family and this
will help me help protect them going
forward in the future the theatrical cut
ends with thy walking past the window
looking at the stairs and you get the
feeling that the demon might have won
however the directors cut out the scene
and of kinnamon showing up Annie invites
Dyer out for a film it's much like what
he did with Charis and friedkin actually
said that and I'm not lying he said that
Charis was somewhat living on to dire
and that their friendship was starting
again a bit weird and the way they ended
it's very like Casablanca and I think
this is going to be the start of a
beautiful friendship anyway that closes
out the video and I hope you enjoyed the
breakdown let me know your thoughts on
the ending as well you know there's two
versions of it and if you've seen both
I'd love to hear which one you prefer
now if you are thinking about
re-watching the movie and want to know
what one to go with then awesome
differences that you have to bear in
mind the subliminal Poppins and face
changes happen in the version you've
never seen before which is also called
the director's cut you're more of a kind
of I don't know subtle one then then I
would say the theatrical ones for you
personally I prefer the little pops and
stuff but that's more because I like
doing Easter egg videos and and pointing
out things at unserted into frames
either way the film still stands as one
of the best Horrors ever made and you
know what I hope you enjoy this journey
with us back through the film if you
want me out still watching definitely
check out our brighten of The Shining
which I still think is one of the best
breakdowns on the channel also I know a
lot of you guys after seeing us cover
Alien 3 so yes gonna put myself through
that for the next video and I hope you
come back with that in the next couple
of weeks by the way a huge thank you for
saying through the breakdown I've been
Paul you've been the best and I'll see
you next time take care peace foreign